[Music]
um
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm madison and i decided to join my
club after watching ladder with crowders
change my mind segments on youtube and
there's really not anything like it
wouldn't it be great if men didn't rape
who are you arguing with my name is seth
downing coming to you live from germany
i joined mud club
when stephen inspired me
to finally stand up for my beliefs
especially since that was my first year
college campus i want to see you
alongside me fighting like hell i want
to see you
coming up with solutions my name is
terry allen tucker
i'm a veteran and i joined the student
crowder and mug club because i like the
banner
i like the fact that they're willing to
go to subjects that are practically
banned everywhere else here's your cape
super aid
it's just the new hero and everything
the hero no one wants what you deserve
yes
hi my name is hallie we joined my club
it's a support forever comes back and we
love every second of it
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
well all right then hello youtube
[Laughter]
it's your old pal i was hot we're back
back on youtube uh big a big uh big deal
for us because uh well i mean it happens
every now and then uh
but
here and there quite often however we
are back here uh we don't know how long
that's going to be we'll see
no response from youtube's lawyers just
to let you know as of yet as of this
airing and look let me i just want to
make something really clear to everybody
watching first off hit that like button
and comment share if you can today to
let people know because the youtube
algorithm gets rid of you so smash that
like button you have that yeah look
right there yeah
and i want to let you guys know that
this show goes on monday through
thursday period 10 a.m eastern it's very
important that you know
if you're if you're looking for it and
you don't find it here it's going on
somewhere else so you can go over to
rumble
uh that's where you can watch the video
cast of course mug club you get an extra
45 minutes of show uh every single day
so that's the best way you can support
us because uh you know youtube don't pay
nothing
but no mo no the show is going on it
just may not be here we have no idea how
long it'll go when you start quoting the
c they start they start banning us for
quoting the cdc and stuff
who knew by the way we broke up with you
last week youtube how does it feel yeah
you could have been back oh i'm sure i'm
sure they're losing sleep i know yeah oh
no like the princess and the p only it's
a thousand dollar bill underneath her
mattresses of other thousand dollar
bills
it's true it's the it's the the
principle the moment yeah it's a
principle matter and we have a promo
code fight like hell you get twenty
dollars off uh if you go to
livecar.com we're going to be talking
about a lot today look right off the bat
figured we would uh
go in the paint lockdowns
no good
no work we're going to do a segment on
lockdown but also give you the data
uh the actual um
the actual research that has been
conducted there's been a lot right we
have a good data set now uh and i want
to sort of point out the the risk reward
and ask you if you think that it was
worth the risk but more importantly we
are going to also fact check the fact
checkers who have said that actually
these claims are untrue uh lockdowns
you know they don't say work they say
but lockdowns you know
no we don't snopes politifact washington
post and reuters what do you mean well
do i really need to say it
yes i'd prefer it
it would help if you could so we'll get
to that but first gerald a how are you
i'm well sir how are you doing fine how
does it feel to be back on youtube yeah
it's a mixed bag it really is oh it's a
mixed bag just because i can't uh say
things you know like uh
cdc things right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah who things as well can't say that
right right hunter biden new york post
things at one point couldn't say that
yeah we can't say the the the uh the t
word well i was what's between fairness
i was working on my training this week
on an old tourist and yeah that's
they're known to go out they are yes
yeah yes ford tour especially on the
fords yeah yeah the old ones the old
yeah new ones the old ford transits
that's the problem
lipstick on that one nope how are you
quarterback doing good yeah happy
halloween everybody have a late
halloween yeah yeah this is the scariest
thing
you would be saying it today yesterday
yeah your people celebrate it on the
first
and dave landau is here he will be in
philadelphia
neighborhoods and trick-or-treating god
knows what hour
it never stops it's really more
30 yeah all right oh dressed november
1st it's the morning that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying it's
unexpected as [ __ ] candy don't stop
candy don't stop dressed as a robber
again huh
why are you in my house i just
trick-or-treating oh yeah i got all the
pieces to come yeah i got a unicef box
it's this duffel bag [ __ ]
[Music]
is unicef an american thing too do you
guys have that uh oh we collect money it
has a little pictures of the kids the
one kid in his arm like is it a civil
war i don't even know what the money
went to i'm not sure i know when i get
the invite to donate i throw in the
trash
of course i donate yeah no actually i
donate why donate i donate a ton but i
don't want to go to cvs like would you
like to donate one dollar to i don't you
know what i know you're going to sit
here and judge me but i have no idea as
to whether it's going to go let's say to
a local church or to a salvation army
where it's going to help rebuild a roof
or put food on some clothes some kid's
back you know sorry food on some clothes
back whatever happens something like
that if you're like your former vice
president uh put food on some kid's
table or clothes on his back or if it's
going to be like bono's one foundation
who ironically gave less than one
percent of all proceeds
i do the roundup unless it's like 98
cents and then i'm like no
[Laughter]
what am i a rockefeller yeah but either
way someone's getting a receipt printed
at cvs that rival circuit city and can
circle the equator four times while they
talk about their new green policy right
toilet paper in my neighbor's house with
it on devil's right yes
get a little moist it becomes paper
mache oh shoot i love two dollars off
adele says soon i meant i wanted that
one uh november 5th through 6th
dave landau's going to be at helium in
philadelphia yes don't get sexually
assaulted on any trains because people
won't do anything in philly
tell me what to do how are you dave uh
good i'm going to wear something low-cut
under the trains and fill it up oh yeah
he was looking for a fun saturday yes no
uh good i can't complain got home uh
went a little trick-or-treating last
night
went as a pile of uh dead beagles
topical was it like was it like a lady
gaga meat suit were you just wearing a
yes you were wearing a suit total meat
so my son was a sand fly
eating your head yeah that was great
i was snoopy he was chasing me right and
you're trying to bark but can't because
you don't have vocal chords well no you
don't want to hear the duck cry i uh
it's a little annoying
take the tear ducts out of a puppy what
a gentleman yeah yeah so i uh uh no
truth no this truth is stupid um no we
went as ghostbusters it was awesome oh
no none of that remake crap no no no no
no no no no no no yes we went to school
yeah yeah i was i was melissa mccarthy
right right and he was transgender
blackface yes i'm sure that that yeah
what are they what are they what do you
want to do you want us to be like why
are you dressing up like
how can you dress up as a new
ghostbusters i don't know you can't it's
black face it's it's transgender face
what you're saying now is the thing
which is just just a bad face right the
new ghostbusters too looked really
awesome until they started showing the
like ghosts yeah
yeah i don't know yeah dave by the way
if i may add you have a very nice shirt
on thank you taste uh well thank you
uh it was contractual ah yes that's true
well these are these are i actually like
them they're super soft well yeah
they're they're very nice they're
available at crowdershop.com
all the better to rape you with on the
philly train yes well totally believable
guys the target i i tell you though for
a guy who with uh how can i put this
perky nipples there's certain shirts
that you wear that you just
you don't feel comfortable yeah no this
is the right amount of softness where i
can get away with without taping that
you're running a marathon yeah like i do
everywhere i go without having to lie to
people telling them that you're running
a half marathon exactly like i'm just
training that's why training dave you
don't look like a notice the new balance
and uh
the tape
notice the new balance with planters
fasciitis
so i'm getting ready for my big marathon
yeah and then after the diabetes kicks
in you can be another terry fox oh
then i'll raise money for my unicef
break yourself [ __ ] so
we have speaking of halloween
oh and a little bit of a hangover of a
candy hangover yeah
we have lizzo who had an interesting
halloween costume
as
the thing is if i describe this you're
going to think that i'm lying to you but
this is but so this is lizzo
as from what i understand baby
yoda
[Music]
oh yeah well baby yoda always shows his
tits
remember that's part of his charm
twerk i missed
cake too much says
[Music]
going through that crosswalk i'm rolling
here
all right what character out of the star
wars everything do you think she dresses
up as first jabba never ever ever would
you say baby anything no okay small
adult minor version no not not going to
happen what was it baby yo
trench coat it doesn't make any sense
either baby yoda's a flasher or selling
watches yeah that's got a little trench
coat
rolex do you think it is lightsaber
is it moving i'm shaking it oh my gosh
maybe mel brooks is yogurt yeah yeah i
have no idea pizza that was supposed to
be baby that was supposed to be baby
yoda baby
as opposed to dub baby yoda where he
just beat a guy in roller skates for no
reason different different yoda beat up
a mandalorian who knew
seems like grown-ass yoda yeah that's a
no
like groan that's that's yoda who's been
on a planet without a gravitational
force for a while right and allowed to
grow beyond their normal parameters
that was also in a thong and showing his
tits well that's hard to fit as a
description it's really long now that's
that's plus that's jabba the hutt had
sex with baby yoda yeah
oh that's what happened
let's get it
[Music]
[Laughter]
scale lies
dr angry i'm late for meeting with
schumer i am
okay
twins so
how much what do you think she went to
home depot and was like give me a gallon
of bear paint
and i said no no here's the five gallon
bucket
you're gonna need this
she asked for bear spray that's just
yeah she didn't ask for it they just
bear spray just
it's lizzo again
put the repellent in the doorway yeah
the power of christ compels you oh i
think she looks hot so you guys are
wrong yeah you know listen
different strokes okay uh i have a
couple of questions that will definitely
be a stroke here's a question for you
uh and then you know um she'll have the
cherry fox leg in due time
sugar former vice president joe biden
actually do you believe he actually
soiled his pants this is my first
question to you i'm going to ask you
about lockdown serious question but
there's a serious question because
there's a rumor circulating and we do
have some footage that i want to in
in totality right when you take it take
the information in tandem uh i think
there's a there's a strong case to be
made um before that though over the
weekend gensake was um
and her thoughts and prayers are
diagnosed with kovid 19. it's a pandemic
dave yes it is a pandemic you know that
the breakthrough cases
are uh they're very rare well they're
very rare and for some reason sometimes
people are vaccinated but i don't think
that the breakthrough cases are
incredibly rare so
had one of the incredibly rare
breakthrough cases and we actually have
an exclusive uh interview with her on
the subject
oh wow she seems angry well you know
what looks like she must have a high
viral load oh yeah it's coming out of
her nose she's definitely got a nicer
tan yeah yeah yeah usually she freckles
more yeah she freckles more you would
think so it just burns yeah good for her
that's more of a that's more of a
sunlight burn thing just she starts
actually smoking yeah she does better at
night if you open those white house
drapes
midnight saki okay i bet you she sleeps
in a coffin yeah
and she rises out of it
it's like there's not a choice of eight
just laying around no no no no
i have no doubt she sleeps in a coffin i
need to keep one near that's what
happens before she just gets out and
just immediate sex like it's normal she
just gets out before everything
no
all right jim acosta i'm going to go to
yeah
so
here's another thing this is why we need
the patriarchy and what do i mean look a
lot of people don't understand i'm going
to show you a video i warned you it's
disturbing uh it happened on a new york
subway
i'm not joking there was a story that
happened two weeks ago in philly someone
was raped on the train nobody did
anything
and this happened in on a new york
subway and and keep in mind
that this did not happen in i know a lot
of people who are minorities and have
definitely
absolutely have legitimate grievances
with the way things were done but women
who have grievances with patriarchy in a
lot of ways don't understand that men
were humiliated and punished severely if
there was any kind of abuse of a woman
that was discovered in private or in
public this idea that there was a
culture where men were free to beat up
women no that's actually not the case
that's what the whip you've heard the
term whipping post it was primarily used
for domestic abusers and then if your
wife beat you
you were also dragged through the street
and humiliated because you were a giant
[ __ ] so this is how culture used to be
and uh they say chivalry is dead uh but
i think it's quite
i think it's quite more substantial than
that this happened uh this last week on
a new york subway here you go
my train riding and
save them
so he's accusing her being a racist she
said take a chill pill
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
now there's so much wrong with that clip
yeah that's the least surprising thing
i've ever seen on a new york subway no i
know that's gonna say yeah i think this
is just typical now a part of me thinks
probably got what they voted for um you
know when you think of pink hair it's
just an estimate doesn't matter just
again i don't know some rumors have been
circling that that guy there is a
boyfriend
whether he is or not
someone needs to get their ass kicked
now the problem is when you're on this
new york subway look here's the option
if it wasn't being recorded guy steps in
beats the guy's ass guess what you're
guilty of the hate crime you lose your
second amendment rights and this guy can
go out on cashless bail because as you
see he was trying to set the narrative
that she was racist that she was racist
for asking him to take a chill pill uh
the other option is you do something and
you have a group of black americans in
the subway who kick the crap out of you
despite having seen him hit a woman this
is a very tough set but this is the
problem this is the problem with right
now in this country going uh uh i'm a
white guy black guy man hits woman in
the face by the way like a [ __ ] she's
she stays up like a champ like jacob
never got me down you never got me down
you colored subway uh
subway fella never got me down that's
what she said so i i will say kudos to
her yeah
this is one of those situations where it
should be oh someone hits woman gets his
ass kicked of course regardless of race
i thought this was an absolute known
thing that was going to happen you hit i
mean
look at that video not one guy steps in
no way he looks up he goes like which
bernard gets when you need him i know
and and by the way this guy
this guy did it in front of his kids did
you see his son standing right there
watching him hit i would kick his ass in
front of his kids and i looked the first
time his kids saw that no it's not the
first to not of course not but it should
have been one of the times where he saw
his dad get his ass kicked for doing
something you know what let's even say
this let's people say oh tough guy okay
maybe let's say the guy kicks my ass
let's say the guy you know he was just
he he pulled that punch
doesn't matter you're gonna make him
wish he didn't do it in public you're
gonna take his ear his lips something
you gotta make it sting and make him
wish that he didn't act that way in
public yeah and nobody on that train
does anything back in the day you could
duel the son of a [ __ ] think of that
for a second slap him across he's
guessing you'd win in a fight judging by
how she took the punch yeah i mean she
took it like a champ yeah she did
honestly
she's the guy right the guy next to her
here if you go back to that video the
guy next to her still has his back
turned to the guy and he's doing this
with her like her you go back
yeah he's he he brings up his hand to
her like you you stay back you used to
that does nothing and also exposes
himself to this guy here's the thing
everyone would like to say i would have
knocked that full out look you're not
going to react that quickly when this
happens right a girl gets hit well it's
shocking you'll be like what yeah that
guy just hit a woman yeah so it's going
to take a profit a process but you know
what you should do
ma'am are you recording okay please
continue recording everyone step back
this man's about to learn a lesson yeah
about to fight and it should have
happened by five six seven ten guys
should have stepped up and said
that's not going to happen on the train
well thank god we don't have that toxic
masculinity anymore and this is the
problem with teaching young men that all
violence is bad i was raised in montreal
okay i went to centennial regional high
school in greenfield park you guys can
look we had a zero tolerance policy
which meant if you were turtling and a
guy was wailing on you and you pushed
him away you both got suspended
stupid because it was all violence it
was all the same and we've conditioned a
generation of men
to not stand up for themselves we've
conditioned a young generation of men to
see everything through the prism of race
we've conditioned a young generation of
men to believe that any of their natural
masculine urges including by the way
that of protecting our women has been
vilified and so do you know what happens
the evil run free yeah absolutely
all evil needs is for good men to do
nothing right that's a famous quote and
my dad did a great job when i was a kid
he said you better i was huge i was much
bigger than all the other kids he goes
you better not ever start a fight he
goes but if it gets started you better
finish it and by the way if the school
does something to you and you're just
defending yourself
we will go out for cake yeah right i
don't care if they suspend you they are
wrong you are right you can defend
yourself my dad used to tell me to
defend myself he was like bill hader in
uh was it one wonderland what was that
summer where he was working at the water
park yeah wonderland yeah wonderland my
dad was like my dad was saying you know
if they call me down in the office like
give me a reason he wanted to go down
come on and i swear to you the one time
i stood up to a bullet i was too big of
a pansy to punch him in the face because
i figured that was so i just got on top
of him and i went ralphy but kept
punching him in the ribs wow and he was
laughing until he was like ah and the
body shuts down until it hurt yeah and
then i got call of the office and uh i
said well if you have a problem with my
behavior you can call my father it's and
the number back then was six seven two
six eight one zero there you go
my son got you my son
she said you're being rude to mrs messer
in the third person
i said maybe well that's something you
need to discuss with my father and i
zipped my lips
and he took me out for ice cream
yeah you should have yeah you were gonna
say something no my son cracked a kid in
the face with the book that was on
camera who was four years older than him
way bigger bullying him and they had a
bunch of cameras and that's just how it
is because nobody wants to get sued
right and they said to talk to him about
that and i was like for def all right so
i'm like just make sure there's no
cameras
and i was dead check your corners yeah
like don't right you mean congratulate
him for that of course i would have
bought him a trophy
stand up for yourself there's nothing
wrong with that and this that that is
the problem i've i lived in new york in
harlem there were women getting sexually
assaulted on the subway while people
stood around and recorded it and nobody
did anything oh yeah this is a constant
issue in in that city that's absolutely
a constant issue and it was not a
constant issue at the time of what you
refer to as patriarchy right when
chivalry actually existed this idea it
was never acceptable to abuse a woman in
the society did it happen because women
were quieter and they were they stayed
at home i'm sure it did in the 1950s but
this idea that in society it was
acceptable it was absolutely
reprehensible certainly in the early
1900s look up whipping post look up a
previous interview with karen strong and
you know what yeah this is a perfect
example of when people talk about other
economies and other worlds uh other
countries in the world if we can find
this we'll use it for mud club there's a
video in russia where these two gypsies
are in the park and a guy is walking by
with his wife or girlfriend he's in like
an old jogging suit
and the one gypsy turns around and
backhands his wife
and he
beats the hell out of both of them you
can tell he's a boxer he knocks one out
other one gets up knocks him out to the
point where his wife starts yelling like
yuri no
it's always yuri yeah
so anyway look it's an awful night for
an awful person well yes of course but
try that in a red state really seriously
something like this happens the only way
is to avoid this look yeah they want you
in big cities no they want you on mass
transit no they don't want to have the
right to defend yourself no no you know
what you do too with that guy what you
do is you say this is what you should be
able to do hey sir hold on are you
recording sure are you recording good
everyone says hey sir i'm sorry are you
armed and if the answer is yes boom
that's it
are you armed no all right it's just
hands yeah but if the guy hits a woman
and he's armed okay
then you call the cops and you wait
that's where it's entirely appropriate
for your right to self-defense yeah she
could have shot him she should have yeah
that should have but could could have
should have but you can't even carry it
you can't even carry a taser there no
you can't you can't do anything no i
mean you can only carry bear spray
that's only good when lizzo gets on the
c train every night well yeah
if you want to take baby yoda yeah
well the whole that's how they built the
new green line you know in the upper
east side was they just had her walk
through the tunnel
got a new subway brother gotta work
banners the hulk again that's the whole
thing that we see as many always angry
we we know where the line is because
other men tell us when we've crossed it
like you've crossed the line i called
one of my friend's sister didn't know is
his sister the b word he's like ah crap
and then he had to like punch me in the
stomach and i didn't know what was going
on right he let me know i crossed the
line nobody has ever told that guy
that's the line so i'm not i don't want
this guy to get his butt kicked just
for retribution i want him to know where
the line is so that he doesn't do
something even worse like i really do
like i don't know this guy could have
been having a really bad day he did
something reprehensible
he could have been just in a really
terrible moment i don't care he needs to
know where the line is and nobody has
ever showed him that he should be
sentenced to riding the the philly train
non-stop until something happens yeah
nothing happened today okay get back on
uh by the way you can uh you know we
don't need a plug people know i'm on
instagram and tick tock but it's a live
show monday through thursday 10 am
eastern if you do not see it here on
youtube tune in at rumble or on mug club
uh okay elon musk here's the story did
you guys know this the musk before we
get to lockdowns didn't work uh and if
there's anything by the way specifically
if you guys are watching right now that
you think we need to hit right off the
bat we'll be doing a whole written house
live stream
once they're done with the uh the jury
selection they actually go to trial
uh according to elon
his new school in texas will be called
the texas institute of technology and uh
science nice
the acronym of course spells tits and
unfortunately elon school um
has become a very unsafe place already
for feminists
this week in feminism
[Music]
so yeah no i was just walking to class
oh my
did joe biden poop himself is the next
story
i'm betting yes how did elon party
missed that
tits yeah no there's no way of course he
did it i feel like he did it as a joke
yeah that's but that's like a several
billion dollar joke well i mean he can
afford to make it into the government
yes i wanted to be a school for
engineering and um
it will be called the texas institute of
technology and science
i got my phd in tits
their shirts would sell out i guarantee
you of course and their white hats in
the 90s yes
like it's just such a bad
stupid old joke though
it's like come on
it's perfect he did it i kind of like it
it's such a college thing though that
you're trying to get rid of you know
it's like ah it's a good like it's like
a duke lacrosse joke right even though
they were innocent which i had no idea
i watched a documentary on a plane and i
was like i've been making guilty jokes
we knew that the whole time uh i
remember duke lacrosse mattress girl
manchester united va these were all the
rape cases yeah the major ones in public
were largely fake yes
not to be confused with bill clinton and
juanita broderick he raped a bro that
was actually true and most of the race
crimes the poop swastika the banana the
new yeah the banana the dana
smallet
i don't think biden did a poop swastika
uh well who knows i mean he means
he was in an office at the time was he i
don't know i i'm not saying is his his
brown star versus a cookie cutter yeah i
think one of the popes would have made a
swastika yeah yeah that german fella
yeah that german that rat singer yeah oh
yeah yeah i don't know i have no idea i
don't know what they were thinking that
that smoke came out black and red
there's two things that uh old germans
love it's poop and swastikas yes
absolutely i've always said that it's
not really a love it's more of an
appreciation some paint with watercolors
that's true and some make a public some
painting in fecal matter a picasso
oh geez
you're like tits is a bad joke i know
casa i'm gonna i'm picking up puns it's
a jason poop well somebody took out my
acronyms
all right uh here's we've joked for a
long time that joe biden has been
soiling himself and it's funny and i
make no apologies not exactly i mean you
know because he's older than time
so
the suspicions they rose further there
was this happened last week this bizarre
moment where he was it looked very much
here's the thing if you're 97 and you
know that people think you're pooping
yourself there are just certain body
positions you don't take right yeah it's
like you know and hold for a long time
like someone should have him watching
tape like an nfl team you know with a
laser only it's a modium commercials
like see this right here you don't want
to do that
this is a no so here he was trying
really hard not to crap himself
about that with just in terms of
inflation
you had told uh us at the town hall i
think it was in july
that
this was just near translation
germany recently talked to like 67
uh financial experts
that's a long prayer wow i got a clip
for you too that shows in the past he
was probably trying to give like a call
for help oh yeah yeah all right let's
see
what
oh
oh there it is we should have seen the
signs
no that's not a barry pepper kiss his
cross and say a couple verses that's
he's praying to every god he can think
of to avoid soiling himself
vishnu
because anderson cooper will identify
that scent right away he's like a t-rex
with movement
you see cooper like head down he's like
if i look at him i gotta go what what
the hell are you doing yeah he's like
i'm reading the question i'm reading the
questions all right you just think it
smells like lunch
look guys guys guys that's that's what i
meant that's not right he doesn't like
good food no moon pies not that he eats
same thing with don lemon they're
notoriously they're notoriously
pedestrian eaters good point yeah they
are that's true they're just they're
regular joes right yeah exactly uh over
the weekend though reporter amy
tarkanian tweeted uh i don't know what
that tarkanian is that her name i don't
know so she reported that uh the
suspected reason for biden's vatican
visit going too long which seems
surprising considering you know the
guy's meeting with the pope and he's the
most uh radically pro-abortion president
that we've had really him and obama
um the word around rome she wrote is
that biden's meeting with the pope was
unusually long because biden had a bit
of a bathroom accident at the vatican
and it had to be addressed prior to him
leaving i know we often joke about this
but this is the actual rumor going
around rome right now and by the way the
pope was angriest when the pope find out
that uh biden took the pope mobile for a
joy ride so that's one of those
gotta hose that down now i thought that
was poop proof see that on here that
shit's alpaca
tell the altar boys to take their shirts
off and clean it up yes
immediately soapy like that's probably
what he assumed at first it was the
ultimate yeah put on uptown girl and let
them dance and clean it yes
[Laughter]
anyone have uh anyone have the uh the
single for only the good die young
any billy jewel yeah we'll just switch
the word from girls to boys
sooner or later we'll go on a date you
know dating me much more fun
cause you know the pope likes them young
don't tell the police even one right
i don't know what the police are in the
vatican but here's the deal i think he
pooped i think that joe biden uh so i
don't know here's what bothers me too
here and this by this is entirely
conjecture we're going to get to the
virginia race we're going to get to the
lockdowns not working but what bothers
me is that
the quote is a bathroom accident well
there's no accident in the bathroom
you're already there it's involved
is that what they're saying well yeah
that's true separate incidents i think
they refer to as double-breasted as the
bathroom ah yes that's i think we're
splitting hairs here they were running
in with a pair of brown pants yes
exactly right just to make sure what a
headline what a trash world we live in
now all of a sudden he asks to wear a
presence he has to wear a deacon's shawl
huh yeah i think i look good in the
bishop
cloak yeah you know you know
tarp like or the fryer thing with the
rope around the waist it's brown right i
like where do i get the red shoes what
can brown do first i think i need to do
penance do you have any uh burlap
something uncle phil would wear like a
tashiki i'm a huge fan of febreze too
just bring it all pooper eve and i don't
care yeah it doesn't matter
you got any of that uh
frankincense
i need some merch you must have some
myrrh here or even a south
i see you have an unusual amount of gold
oh it's weird ah oh it's cold
frankincense slippery gold come on
come on
so uh
colin kaepernick also here's another one
compared the nfl to slavery and his new
netflix special absolutely have so much
to cover because our first day back on
youtube here uh he suggested that the
nfl combine is
you know what i can't even describe it
to you i could tell you that he compared
it to slavery it's worse but it's not
that he is he didn't say in some way you
know it's comparable to slavery that
we're locked down in these contracts
no it's an episode of it's it's roots
with its roots with a naked gun afro
that's well yeah and frederick douglass
got a great deal from reebok right yes
[Laughter]
emmett taylor was an adidas man
uh all right here you go here's the
netflix clip
before they put you on the field team
sir
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact whatever
oh maybe you can cry about your dignity
into your 126 million dollar contract
you rube
by the way those guys look good that's
the kind of body i'm going for
look at this
so insulting to actual slaves
so
next coming up best one we got
500
yeah that's what that's what's going on
just think about that for a second
that'd be roots what's your name boy
what's your signing bonus we're about to
offer you 10 million
15 million ah
damn it fullback just go down to 12.
you're starting too high on the deal
all right
13 million no boy
be a good crazy vince young sorry we
missed one right and then they give you
all this one exactly yeah
[Music]
many [ __ ] have to be beaten in an
elevator for you to know we're going to
see some clarity actually no no no you
want him like that you just wanted him
to do that on the field right okay yeah
i don't want him to do it you don't want
him to do it at the auction no no no no
no it's just what no oh no my slave
colin kaepernick got his ass kicked
by who anyone else in the league
i think he got replaced by blaine
gabbert
and if you know anything about football
which you don't i don't you you should
you've guessed all those questions
correctly i think you might be lying
blake gabbard is not a good quarterback
well his name's blaine gabbard doesn't
sound like a good anything that sounds
like he should be freaked out by
something david blaine does oh damn bad
yeah
that's how you get him to run down the
field they'd be sound david that's what
i would do if i were playing against a
team because let's be honest
mostly uh african american i would put
david blaine in my ends in sports and i
would just put him behind my line my
running line like ah [ __ ] and they would
run all the way it'd be touched down
every time and he would make the end
zone disappear or what no no they're
terrified of magic
black people
yeah he'd have you i'd have him do like
a trick like all right that's actually
this is your card oh
i'm open
yeah they don't not like magic tricks
really well they love them but they get
scared yeah they love them
maybe they know something freaked out
it's like whites and haunted houses
yeah yeah i blacked out through haunted
houses like saying no yeah they
punched me somewhere yeah they don't
care what kind of haunted house do you
ever have to have in detroit to make an
impression exactly well you basically
just take the bombed out houses well
yeah it's where art it's where arsonery
that's a term is very useful in detroit
yes what do you just make it like really
nice yeah but like instead it's like
clear
bucket of nails and you're like all
right haunted house yeah if you want to
ruin a neighborhood you just put up a
nice house
and they're like what we're just trying
to sell dope what's the name of the guy
who plays colin kaepernick it's blaine
gabbert all right come on up here boy
blaine gabbot
is he white i don't know well there goes
the slave theory no i'm just saying he
was i figured he's white his name's
blaine yeah yeah that's not a black now
who here wants to bid on mr t-bow they
call him mr tebow
all right here we're gonna sell him to
the highest bidder with pieces on the
back end and of course the signing bonus
of a few million dollars yeah that'd be
nice
but he's kneeling that's prayer yeah oh
yeah
he didn't start oh that's plain gavin
that's playing gabbard oh
he didn't start neal until he started
sucking all right his career was over
hey by the way i don't know if you know
this colin kaepernick with the oj naked
gun fro and not all froze just his fro
is silly uh his current night deal is
like millions of dollars yeah keep in
mind nike lobbied against a bill
uh that was targeting forced labor in
xinjiang ah yeah at least he supports
actual slavery right yeah wait a minute
nike's shoes aren't all made in america
by gentlemen hands you wouldn't think
they're not all made by blaine what's
his name garrett gabbard dabber
oh that's right they're made by kids yes
they're made by kids preferably muslim
uyghur kids yes yes i'm just glad that
so uyghurs can buy them here right
it's a fubu genre it really is yeah what
absolutely what happened all right what
eminem
by the way also a quarter of the nfl is
what i see is it really but you know
what african slave traders they were
they they sold some white people too and
there's even a corner pack i think
what's a cornerback an actual white zone
do we have a white cornerback is it an
actual position i don't know is that in
my life is there still a white
cornerback in the nfl it's true who i
don't know it's gotta be no
come on troy somebody or other now he'll
be out by the end of the year there's no
way in two years they're going to be
extinct yeah well i'm just saying that
looks like that looks like an episode of
roots i may know a lot about you looks
like roots to me 12 years a slave maybe
a little moonlight in there steven the
nfl field is the new plantation
nfl so white let's start it yeah it's a
problem
get ready i prefer the help yeah i like
white savior complex movies yes
actually you know what's funny that
movie came on and my wife had read the
book yeah and uh we went and we saw at
the theater in michigan in a liberal
town
and uh what's his name there the
professor snape mr porter alan rickman
he uh he played ronald reagan in it and
my wife had read the book and the truth
is like lyndon johnson was just awful
and ronald reagan treated them
to help really really well uh and she
knew that going in and so right away
when ronald reagan appears this lady in
theater goes boo
and my wife goes i didn't know we had
racists in the theater
and she's like what my wife goes you'll
see and then
and then he's the only president who
treats him like a human being right
so that was an awkward one i love that
you rubbed off on your wife so much that
she feels compelled to to say something
in a theater she just but she said it
she announced it i didn't know we had
racists in the theater what you'll see
and i was like i guess it pays to read
the book all this time i'd be like why
would i read the book the film's going
to tell me everything i want to know
it's just so i can chastise and insult
other people in the theater for being
racist it would step up my movie
heckling game yes it would so now listen
to close this we're not fans of
kaepernick here but i think there's one
thing that we can all agree on yeah
uh and that that that's that water in
the realm of sports is the best
hydration method there is
uh which is why here at lighter with
crowder we're very proud to announce um
we have very few sponsors per show but
our current sponsorship agreement with
water did you know earth is made of 71
water
doctors recommend we drink at least 1.2
liters of water a day just to be on the
safe side that's a lot of water
water is key to our survival but we
don't just drink it we have fun playing
in it too
we wash ourselves in it and sometimes we
even get stuck in a storm of it
an adult's brain is 65 water and the
other 35 is gin
but maybe that's just me
my wife left me
and she has full custody of the children
that there
that's jeff
my kids call him dad now he's a lawyer
in fact he's her lawyer i remember when
my wife used to brag about being married
to a big time commercial voice-over guy
that was a long time ago when she
used to wear her ring
we used to actually have a house on the
water but now it belongs to the bank
luckily it was only in my name so only
my credit got ruined
[Music]
thank goodness i'm still able to afford
this studio apartment it has this pot
i'm currently filling with water
this pot is the only thing my wife left
behind
besides pain
i'm gonna use it to make some macaroni
and cheese
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah go to lottothecar.com water to get
yours free at your house today yeah very
nice
unless you're in flint deal not
applicable yes no well for legal
liability purposes don't do it there
that just fell out of the news but still
very much a problem yeah it is yeah well
you know what good old michigan
democrats doing a bang-up job h2o hey by
the way uh that's actually where they
would have been right yeah where they
would've been saying in flint what a
shock skater it's better whoa whoa whoa
yeah you're right
flint water is disgusting
so
[Laughter]
we're going to get to this pornography
by the way showing your children in
virginia in a little bit because it ties
into the virginia race but uh first look
this is something we talked about this
early on in the pandemic and i want you
to um comment below if if
what your view is on lockdowns if you
thought they were going to work
beforehand we believe the two weeks
initially made sense but we didn't lock
down right we believe that it made sense
for you know businesses to be able to do
that and to get some kind of support for
two weeks because we believe they were
trying to flatten the curve but we
didn't shut down just to be clear
that being said i don't know if that
makes any sense at all now looking back
even the two weeks and i think we have
enough data to definitively say
lockdowns um
absolutely did not work whatsoever this
is definitive
but let's go back to when they were
telling us that the lockdowns would work
and why they would work
put out an executive order today
new york state on pause
policies that assure
uniform safety for everyone this moment
that we direct a statewide order for
people to stay at home we are confident
that the people of the state of
california will abide by it they'll do
the right thing they'll meet this moment
isn't this stupid
over the course of the last number of
weeks they're available to protect
themselves maybe yoda to protect them
fam their families we're asking for
three weeks
mimi from true caring so sacrifice
everyone is three weeks struggling with
remember that
but the fact of the matter is we're
going to save lives by observing this
order
by using your forehead as a solar panel
we're staying at home
[Music]
thereby helping to protect the
vulnerable
and sparing many families the pain
already felt by those who have lost
loved ones by the way you keep the pearl
necklace i've ever walked by the way you
can't see but her signer is a big black
guy from chip and dale's oh wow
it's i prefer it this way he doesn't
even use his hands of course we don't
let him change the royal gene pool
yeah i wave like this and not all you
commoners have a hundred thousand square
foot home to stay in like i do at
[ __ ] and you can't i'll say that your
your father is in fact your uncle really
oh yes my my nephew's dating or what
wow
oh no oh
what's the what's the proper pejorative
i'm supposed to use these
we're days to all be cousins
could we have some paparazzi follow her
24 7 just to especially particularly
while she's driving an expressway maybe
in a tunnel yeah love
oh very fast
so here's no seat belts in the limousine
no secrets not in a rule it's we mustn't
argue with tradition
those wheels need to have no tread
yes also you'll find your booster seats
there yeah i'm an adult really we
mustn't it's tradition
pomp and circumstance you know
uh so this is uh going back to the
lockdowns to be clear they all told us
this is what we need to do the lockdowns
and then they tried to extend the
lockdowns of course you look at whitmer
of course you look at cuomo in other
words this wasn't two weeks but i just
wanted to take you back in time through
your delorean here so
let me give you some some info all
references are available at
lateralcredit.com christian b
shorev bjornssev what holds a phd in
economics uh at the center of economics
oh very chef from the muppets right yes
yeah it's that i couldn't read the study
i had to put it through google translate
yeah
well the evidence progresses
it's also really weird when he's doing
his medical re when he's doing his you
know he comes out he's like i have a phd
in that well he still has a butcher's
knife
so
phd in economics center of economic
studies and they looked at many
countries i think it was like 20
something countries uh the evidence
presented here suggests that lockdowns
have not significantly affected the
development of mortality in europe they
have nevertheless wreaked economic havoc
in most societies and may lead to a
substantial number of additional deaths
for other reasons the european journal
of clinical investigation found while
small benefits cannot be excluded we do
not find significant benefits on case
growth of more restrictive
non-pharmaceutical interventions similar
reductions in case growth may be
achievable with less restrictive
interventions a university of chicago
study showed the virus spread more in
homes than actual workplaces per capita
transmission rates on-site fell
dramatically usually to levels below
household transmission now this is
something that we know this is something
that is definitive again the left wants
to say hey follow the science but then
they cite for example fouchy one study
saying that you're 57 times more likely
to die from covet if you were
unvaccinated which comes from one small
scale we did that on rumble one small
scale study uh in one county
so here's what is most troublesome is
the fact checkers because if you run a
search right now did were lockdowns
unsuccessful did lockdowns work you're
gonna find the fact checkers who by the
way we don't know because it's not
transparent it's all very opaque
are authoritative sources to youtube
facebook twitter right this study when
you talk about university of chicago
when you're talking about someone with a
phd who's done an international
meta-analysis
may be
fat checked with misinformation
but then you may have snopes and you may
have reuters and politifact and they're
not being fact-checked but let me show
you the level of quality
this is why i wanted to do this so you
can see the argument that lockdowns have
not worked and i want to show you the
authoritative left sources arguing that
lockdowns have worked i want you to see
their fact check so that you have both
sides of this issue
and i would only present this to you if
i believed that one was substantially
stronger because i don't like doing
straw men so this is actually fact fact
checking fact checkers right oh yeah i
don't know if we do we used to have that
as a sex yeah oh well there we go
so health feedback is uh one of the uh
authoritative sources for some reason ah
uh the science editor sophie faisal
wrote
lockdowns lead to a significant
reductions making the saying the claim
is not really true right uh significant
reduction in physical interactions
between people which reduce the
transmission of coven 19 and save lives
so that's pretty broad although
lockdowns have also contributed to
economic recession and high unemployment
rates they can pay off in the long run
another real thing of how many people
who would die had they not been
implemented
keep in mind when this person
and we'll get to uh reuters and i think
politifact in a second when this person
wrote this these other published studies
had already been available but she goes
this authoritative source she's
rebutting studies using data from wallet
hub
this is what they do they go well
it sounds made up it's misleading if you
look at it it's misleading uh these
studies uh you know uh
you're citing wallet hub
as opposed to swedish chef over there
from well i don't know about that
website that sounds just like porn
why didn't this is my question why when
they said these claims are misleading
didn't they fact check the legitimate
sources the published research this is
the issue right one look i'm not saying
that there's no objective truth what i
am saying though at this point this is
why it is more important than ever for
you to be informed and for you to look
at both sides of the issue here i'm not
saying there is no objective truth i'm
not a postmodernist what i am saying is
it is very easy for anyone to claim that
anything is the truth right now
so this idea that we're following the
science
no they're not these fact checkers are
not if they wanted to follow the science
they would say robust debate people use
that term a lot we need robust debate
what does that mean the strongest
arguments presented from both sides but
the authoritative sources are more
interested in straw manning you're going
well people it's a mis it's a misleading
study from wallet hub that's not the
argument that's not the robust
presented argument from the right yeah
and just look this is not the first time
we've had to deal with this either this
is not like they were like oh we've
never tried lockdowns before we've never
tried to figure this out with a global
pandemic yes we did 1918. right we tried
the very same thing and i've quoted this
before and it was in a book that i was
reading that was really compelling the
united states army during a time of war
tried locking troops down people that
have to run and could basically be shot
eventually
if they didn't listen to orders right
those people they tried locking them
down and they didn't find any
statistical significance between
sorry i thought we're talking about the
nfl combine no no we're going back there
yeah go wrong
no the united states army we've known
this for over a hundred years and
basically the conclusion from those
studies that they did was that a general
public lockdown would not be well and i
know that but what i'm saying is now we
have data that is definitive no i'm
saying that they knew it was already
they knew it was but my point now is
they're lying in their face again yeah
this is the issue here is they go oh
wallet hub hold on a second let's look
at the let's look at the title i think
if you look at any shut-in who never
goes out we can admit they're always
very healthy and balanced jesus yes
there's no mental strain being locked in
your home would be a problem like that
ap reporter who was on the plane when
the southwest pilot said let's go
brandon she's like let me in the cockpit
let me let me in the cockpit did you
hear that story she's like let me into
that cockpit like no yes yes yes i as
well enjoy committing federal felonies
on airlines when someone
someone ends their speech with a light
quip yeah yes
yeah one thing happened what airline was
it southwest oh of course but aren't the
stewardesses supposed to be hilarious
that that's kind of part of it right
yeah right isn't that everything now and
then one of them gets a little too lippy
you got to put her back in her place
yeah it gets a little bit too roasty
you're like listen [ __ ] yeah a fat lip
is a sign of a bad previous set slash
flight i always just punch him on a
train yeah well you know no one does
anything
choo choo we are living in the golden
era people always look back to the good
old days you're in the good old days
so sophie fessel from health feedback
this was may 10th
okay the casey mulligan from university
of chicago that was already in april the
christian banjorski uh center for
economic science that was march 29th
january 5th was aaron uh benadevid from
the european journal of clinical
investors so the point is these were
available at the point that this
rebuttal was made um and again keep in
mind the entire purpose of the lockdown
was to stop hospitals from being
overwhelmed and that never happened the
hospitals did not become overwhelmed no
they had 77 total patients at uh mercy
in los angeles 182 total patients in the
comfort in new york there was 155
million spent on tents at stony brook
university zero patients so a lot of
people use this you know they tried to
say oh we need to flatten the curve and
they pointed to hospitals being at
capacity they always operate at capacity
i'm starting to have zero patience for
this pandemic right
i know well look ouchy would be happy to
hear it
it's over that's pretty good thank you
it's over yeah it's over now why because
they found out he's a monster yeah
that's exactly can we say that on here
yes i think we can say it because the
beagle thing is out yeah yeah everybody
should know it should be out i mean i
mentioned it on youtube a long time ago
allegedly he has beagles faces eaten by
sand flies are we done yeah i think can
we go back to normal life can we get
past the fouchy chapter here yeah let's
stop the well it's science it's a
beagle's face yeah
so let's just go i thought that we would
have had that after the aids fiasco with
fouchy but yeah the never ending stormy
i will never leave you away all right is
there an aids vaccine no
oh still ow well therapeutics
and some good advice so here's some
other things reuters got in on the
action politifact while they're talking
they wrote they all say that no it's not
really true lockdowns did help right
okay let me read you from writers and
politifact here another study concluded
the effectiveness of these orders
depends critically on the cooperation of
the public they even admit this for
example although california's first in
the nation shelter and place order
carries threats of fines and
incarcerations its effectiveness
fundamentally relies
on social pressure so there you go
that's about creating this society where
you have a bunch of cairns running
around telling people to wear a mask but
here's the thing
lockdowns even by the admission so in
other words we have all these
peer-reviewed journals all of these
published research papers that are
available all research is available all
references at louderwithcrowder.com have
a link in the description it's available
they say well the claims are mostly
false and what do they bring up some
random tweet and it's not even a blue
check mark
they don't refute the authoritative
sources as they would call them
and they even admit
in their own fact check so people just
see misleading and they go all right
okay i'm gonna move on ah four
pinocchios
lee riley professor of infectious
diseases and vaccinology at uc berkeley
that's always a good phrase said the
confusion over whether shutdowns work is
understandable considering states with
some of the toughest mandates are also
experiencing the biggest spikes oh why
but correlation does not equal causation
so i'm sure riley who supports the
lockdowns at uc berkeley despite not
actually doing any kind of a in-depth
research or analysis
uh
has a strong opinion he says
the problem is when these restrictions
are erased or eased sorry or lifted
that's when they see the resurgence
riley explained this is what people are
looking at and saying the restrictions
don't work
self-check
uh-huh
yes yes like no no no no they're saying
lockdowns don't work first off i'm not
even going to address the data because
i am the science second they just think
that they don't work because once the
lock down stop they don't work
so this is insane i rest my case your
honor you were
brilliant
that's phd level so literally this is
they this is what people are looking at
and saying the restrictions don't work
yup
yes we looked at it and it says they
don't that's why they do thank you well
you said it you said it the problem is
when these restrictions are easier
lifted that's when we see the resurgence
so the problem is once we stop the
lockdowns and then you know we get
more than ever
that's what these fake news people are
trying to use to say that the lockdowns
don't work that's where they get
confused no i'm not confused you're a
piece of [ __ ]
by the way you know what we can just
look at some of the what are the
scandinavian nordic countries that
didn't do severe lockdowns and and their
curves look pretty similar yeah to the
rest of europe well florida
exactly florida went from worst at one
point to best and florida also had one
of the highest vaccination rates look i
used to say this we definitively cannot
say that lockdowns make things worse
but we can absolutely say that they have
made they have had a horrible impact on
the economy right and they've had a
horrible impact on uh auxiliary deaths
right from people being depressed from
substance abuse from people being
isolated and we certainly can't say
that they are more effective than places
that didn't lock down we now can say
definitively that they did not work at
all in their intended purpose and they
have had
many catastrophic effects let me list
off a few for you so you have the actual
numbers more money for jeff bezos yes
and and fouchy
yeah bye my doll bye my look at my
pillow my field of white flags because
that's not just put there so you see it
get used to it and worship it it's for
profit
so one of the greatest wealth transfers
in history as a result of these
lockdowns oh shocking the top five
billionaires
five billionaires saw their wealth grow
by a total of 101.7 billion dollars that
i just guess 70 billionaires overall in
this country saw their wealth increase
good i don't know why a company that
brings stuff right to your door would
have increased during a lockdown no i
don't there's no clue especially when
they move to drones no i do yeah why use
people
increase suicide depression depression
uh depressive symptoms were three times
higher during lockdown there was a 31
increase in emergency room mental health
business visits for children who are
aged 12 to 17. wow there's a 300
increase in self-harm doctors uh visits
age 13 to 18. i don't understand why one
would go 12 to 17 the other is 13 to 18.
i feel like there are two people arguing
about age brackets like i think what
really matters here when looking at
adolescents is uh 12 to 13. [ __ ] no
no no just it's all about the 13 to 18
year olds now you're living in the stone
age with your 12 to 17 demographic
studies oh screw you carl you and your
13 to 18.
hey carl i had a full bush when i was
12. yes and a mustache
but you're chaldean it doesn't matter
you're armenian and you still couldn't
grow one oh
maybe you can go cry into your 13 to 18
papers the toxicity of your studies of
your style
right you know i'm talking about system
of a down [ __ ] off you when you're 13
18. your sister had a full one
this meeting's over yeah
a full one of
this guy
my point is she was 18 that's my point
that's my point i swear
i don't know i just find it i just find
it odd again because we do these dives
and yeah deep doesn't numbers why did
they go 12 to 17 and these people go 13
to 18. anyway it's just stupid why not
just standardize it i don't know because
it's science
i mean honestly the 13 to 18 makes more
sense because teenager to adult the 12
to 17 seems odd i don't know why it's
like pre-pubescent or like pubescent-ish
to almost depends on you know it depends
on whether you're middle eastern or not
yeah it really does break down to
backhand it really does when you look at
a gal and you're like you're gonna have
to wax that or boys aren't gonna
somewhere in the prenup is nair so uh uh
increased global poverty by the way u.s
monthly poverty increased by uh almost
two percent uk seven hundred thousand
people were driven into poverty india 75
million people driven into poverty what
and in india that's really poor well
that's yeah that's going from very very
differently poverty i mean they go from
pooping in the streets to pooping in uh
less nice streets yes yes dirtier poop
covered streets i used to do this
on a brick road now it's just red dirt
no no no no no steven the new squatty
potty does nothing
because you don't have one oh i can't
feel my legs i wish we had a bunch of
things to eat there's a cow right there
no
no that we worship don't be crazy that
is insane look at dave being crazy he's
saying eat cow
watch me twist my penis around this rod
like a pretzel and the penis yogi
that is not impressive i know it's
impressive no i think it's no it's 75
you can't do it can you millionaire i
don't care i didn't used to have to do
this but after coving we all had to find
a way to put chutney on the table
what's the point look at that
look he's like a lampshade with my
testicles okay look at that
why do they do this that's my boy i
don't know i don't care if you're
impressed i don't know i have no idea
but there's some dumb broad who's on our
eat pray love journey who decides to go
oh my god i really found myself you know
what you can find my gland's penis tied
around this bow and arrow look i shoot
and my glance penis arrow comes back to
me
oh it's just like a braids oh the
culture here the native food i was
brutally raped on a train and a bus
part of my journey i went to india and
it's super spiritual these people and by
the way i say this because i feel
incredibly empathetic to the people of
india my brother went to india on a
mission trip i think you've been to
india no no cambodia okay sorry but my
brother went i thought you stopped
through india that must have been one of
my brother's friends but uh he went
through india and uh he was like look at
that gerald
when people talk about the chasm of the
middle class oh it's it's it's
unbelievable the poverty is unreal but
people here love to say oh it's so
spiritual yeah right oh my gosh i'm on
my spiritual journey yes i hope that
spiritual journey is going very well for
you um okay
here's something that in our holy texts
is very important custom and that is you
will notice i brought a very large
suitcase you're going to check your bag
i am going to yogi myself into this bag
and you can eat pray love me all the way
through custom
i love it by the way with all the new
people in poverty capitalism has its
work cut out for it because that's the
only thing that's going to lift them
back out of poverty yeah right
government's trying to take control of
everything and screwing it up in india i
don't think so now have i heard that
story all right let's we've got to move
on so anyways forced lockdowns not only
didn't work this is the issue too
there's a reason a lot of people think
there's this disconnect like you know
arnold schwarzenegger you screw your
freedoms your freedoms come with
responsibilities like [ __ ] the maid
yeah your marriage comes with
responsibilities dummy you also didn't
have to have sex with the ugliest thing
that's ever walked the face of the earth
well yeah and then you have your
frankenstein kid and you're like he
doesn't look anything it doesn't look
anything yeah they show up like look
come on look at him at 16 now can't you
see
what what are you looking at
mean brown terminator over there i don't
know him the guy looks like he should be
stuck on wall i don't know
okay
i'll be back you just see him going to
his hummer
yeah this is the guy who yeah he cares
so much about the environment that he
invented driving the military uh
recreational vehicle right yeah six six
miles to the gallon yeah great work
arnold how do you ride the carpool lane
look at him my point here is beef people
try to separate his kitchen let's just
point that out people try and separate
uh freedoms
right you screw your freedoms
it's because we also understand that
long term it's like the stock market you
know i don't know if you've seen this
but the monkey walk monkey throw and i
think it was they span they had several
competitions they've had where they had
these expert stock brokers hedge fund
managers and then they just had one
where a cat walked across i believe it
was a board they had one like a monkey
something with a walk or throwing darts
random statistical random did better
long term than these experts right long
term you double your money every 10
years the market ultimately wins out
okay everyone's been predicting the
collapse of it the point is
i'm getting off in the weeds the point
is this here
long-term freedom wins out
long term if you stuck with freedom it's
not something in this nebulous sort of
uh oh i don't know freedom kind of no
it's written down in plain english by
the way with commas in specific portions
when you're talking about the second
amendment when you're talking about play
when you're talking about the bill of
rights it's very clear now we see
statistically from the data that if we'd
have just stuck with freedom might have
been a little bit painful there and they
got in the early going but long term we
would be better off and the left tries
to separate oh at what point do your
freedoms
and then interfere with x no no no
removing the freedoms creates a
never-ending cycle of x and we need to
understand this from the get-go the next
time this rolls around the delta plus
variant the delta plus plus plus variant
i don't give a rat's ass we now know
that the removal of freedoms
hasn't worked okay now let's move on
speaking of removal of freedoms virginia
we warn your kids to leave
for this segment yeah because we're
going to be reading
what they actually have available in
their virginia libraries yeah we
wouldn't want you to see the information
that's publicly available there so
tomorrow there's a race it's republican
glenn juncken youngkin and he could
actually beat democratic challenger
terry mcauliffe right and so last week
we actually or not last week sorry on
october 13th we covered the loudoun
county sexual assault case you remember
that we yeah boy and a skirt rape two
girls yeah yep we've covered that and
we've talked about it just so you know
uh younkin trailed mcauliffe by just see
i said boy in a skirt youtube now what
are you gonna do
he just quoted them right yeah by the
way when we did that where's your
guidelines now
yunkan trailed mcauliffe by just over
three points he got it i got it you need
to know this we just looked this up
prior when we did our show trailed in by
three points right after we did our show
mcauliffe the democratic challenger
peaked and started falling and now that
that gap is five points
i can't say it was our show that did it
but it happened probably we didn't get
removed right well no we had it up for a
little while right now it was making a
lot of news and he began falling so one
of the things that we're doing this for
is because you guys may say why do i
care about virginia we have the highest
interaction with people in virginia for
our show so a lot of people watch our
main show and then go to crowder bits
channel and kind of do that but usually
it's it's a fraction of that virginia
everybody you guys are going to do both
so if you're watching right now in
virginia go out and vote make sure you
do not let me call off become and a
really important thing too is the
there's a kind of a conflict going on in
virginia yeah about the educational
system yeah yeah and how they've uh
handled not only the rape case but um
there have been a lot of controversies
that have uh appeared yeah they've
multiple have popped up recently and
we're going to read some of this so
we'll just show you if you want to but
we are we are but we'll just show you
the reaction now because parents or as
the fbi categorizes them domestic
terrorists right uh at uh local meetings
in the county of fairfax are pissed do
not interrupt my time
do not interrupt my time
i would like to remind everybody stand
here until my time is restored and my
time is finished these books are in
stock and available in the libraries of
robinson for high school langley and
annandale for 14 year olds when i saw a
teacher express an opinion and suspended
for expressing his religious beliefs i
could no longer stay silent when did it
become acceptable to be tolerant only
when someone expresses a view that we
agree with
when did it become appropriate to
silence those that hold christian
biblical views just because you don't
excuse me can you look this way
excuse me hello school board
you're looking down this is the respect
that you show the people who you work
for you work for us
oh yeah by the way when someone says i'm
going to finish my time if i were for
example if i were in the senate or if i
were there and one of them was like i
yield my time i would have at the ready
no time left for you
they'd be like i'm gonna use my i got
got got got no time i thought you're
gonna go with closing time or something
i just think
let's not use the word play
so uh this is about uh sexual stuff very
to kids um when i finally got old enough
to not be embarrassed talking about this
stuff with my sister we didn't by the
way blur the fellatio this isn't west
virginia it really never occurred to you
to put something into your vagina and
not even a finger it really didn't so
you've never tasted yourself what no
ew
wait you have ha ha of course you should
try
and then this guy has vagina slime but
that would well no this guy imagine that
in dilbert hold on
that is two sisters is what they're
saying one looks like a girl one looks
like a guy
so the guy has a vagina they're supposed
to be two sisters
oh my god that's a far away from
rosemary clooney and that other one who
died of anorexia i don't want to uh
sisters i don't throw feminism under the
bus but do you think you've worked when
they call it vagina's lime yeah
but basically it's the you you can't do
that never such slimey vaginal sisters
it's so they're supposed to lord help
the mister
who touches the slime of my sister
and here is
my lady oh this this is the most
ridiculous
this is the most this is the one look
this is so this is the visual i've been
picturing so now you have uh a boy
little middle picture here little
picture a boy performing fellaini
blowing a woman with a strap on
and the woman the girl who looks like a
boy is saying but i can't feel anything
this was much hotter when it was only in
my imagination yes because you mean it's
an inanimate piece of polymer
what were you expecting you don't have a
penis that's not how this works oh my
gosh why is this if this were
heterosexual couples right showing it to
kids
this is just so at what point do you say
they're trying to turn your kids into
degenerates and i know oh lifestyle no
hold on a second
it's not a lifestyle
if you think you can feel a
feel a fake penis getting blown how did
you make it to high school that's just a
powerful functioning point yeah
i thought i would feel it well then
you're the dumbest person right yes
you're the dumbest bro i've heard about
that phantom
i just thought if i really wanted to
feel it for crying out loud look let's
let's think of this like why are you
saying that that uh isn't uh as
legitimate as uh teaching kids about
heterosexual sex first off because i
think i should learn sex regular first
second we're talking about someone who
uh
i don't know if it's the same person you
talking about vagina slime it looks um
but this is someone who desperately
wants to be a man and so they are
wearing a plastic device also they will
never they will never be able to
reproduce but that's not a glitch that's
a feature right according to the left um
and uh if they go through with the
bottom surgery it'll effectively be a
flesh fleshy version of this where they
also may not be able to experience
innocence
so it's bad for society at large it's
bad for the children it's bad for their
relationship with their parents who have
the right to teach their children about
about sexual interactions at a young age
and it's bad for those in the lgbtqpai
plus community
she has a treasure trail
oh jesus oh my god oh no
no look for real though
she had a she had a belly button
no i think that's a treasure chest well
and the last the last one is basically
an ad for a vibrator an ad for a
vibration ah may i guess i should get
one of these and try it like this let's
seriously okay okay i thought that was a
mouse nope not a mouse not a matter of
speaking
toilet paper exactly right so that that
person basically said this is available
in high school for four you want your 10
year old
your 14 year old daughter reading that
do you really want your 14 year old
daughter hell no the problem is because
it's high school it's totally fine well
this is direct but you have kids they
can have siblings yeah like i'm just
saying like they get to go there and
look at that it's already bad enough
with the internet anyway you guys do
your thing well look seriously
just be interesting i was born in 1950
right so parents look we said the
parents
back then be like hey boys you might
notice that susie over there is wearing
a very nice dress and you may feel
something you've never felt before
whereas right now it's like put on your
fake strap-on
suzy's wearing nothing because it's
racist if she wears anything else to
school absolutely watch her trick and
then use her strap-on yes notice how
she's feeling it none whatsoever
everyone hears a dance now young jimmy
let me let your old man tell you about
vagina slime have you talked to your
sister about sex used to be brother
i don't know i lose track all right so
the parents were pissed hate speech
jimmy
don't tell your sister what i've done to
you
so the parents were pissed right but
another thing that they're pissed about
is that the democratic
guy running for governor mcauliffe said
parents shouldn't make decisions about
their children's education yeah no you
shouldn't have any say in whether your
kids read ads for bullet vibrators and
strap on fellatio let's hear
trigonometry is one thing but it's
another thing where you're like oh
it's just the blowing strap-on class
feels unnecessary well we'll do that
next year this yeah it's nothing but
deconometry let's see if you can let's
see if you can figure out the coke sign
to my tangent all right let's go and i'm
not going to let parents come into
schools and actually take votes out make
their own decision yeah wow we're not
gonna let parents make their own
decisions yeah my parents stop the bill
that i don't think parents should be
telling schools what they should teach
let's you know i get really tired of
everything right well and the bill that
he was talking about uh mcauliffe
vetoing required schools to provide
alternative material to this okay just
alternative material to this that's all
we're saying and desperate to help my
colleagues what would it be penthouse
letters well how about just not this
material yeah exactly
you realize the fight
arnold schwarzenegger was stopped at the
border for muscle magazines yeah women
in bikinis they said it was pornography
can you imagine if it came over they
pulled this oh let's see mr
watson nager if that is your real name
uh
what is this that's bodybuilding
magazine what you don't do bench press
you don't do push-ups or blow a girl
with a fake dildo strapped on a treasure
trail come on
i drew it on the plane
yeah i said others and stuff well how do
you how do you teach your kids about sex
cupcake
i had sex with an ugly stewardess that's
it
but then the pilot said let's go brandon
i was furious very very angry about that
look you used to you had this in your
suitcase the fbi was looking into you no
it used to be if you handed this to a
child or a convicted sex offender done
if i hand to a child bring this up again
if i were to hand to a child
ten years ago a picture middle section
there that middle section an actual
picture for those who have kids again
i'm telling we told you should not be
watching right now that beautiful young
young mixed race girl there at the
beginning i hope she's not watching this
right now please do we say mixed race
we'll go mulatto because i know that i
don't care um it's a good one if i show
a child a penis entering a mouth by the
way a minor
don't know if it's a thirteen a twelve
to seventeen situation or thirteen
18 is pretty fair 18's pretty fair and
it's just gross and but seriously this
would be you would be arrested yeah for
soliciting pornography to a child and by
the way we didn't blur this on purpose
absolutely we're not trying to to be
titillating or selection anything that
we're we're basically trying to show you
what they think is we're not right no no
not in this case
mission failure right good thing i'm
saying dave's gonna need a debrief
dave's out there trying to buy a
strap-on right now to not experience
sexual pleasure need a new zipper right
well she's not experiencing sexual
pleasure so there's that well don't
worry guys so the the media was ready to
step in to help mcauliffe and actually
we have nbc reported on a group carrying
and this is the stupidest thing i've
seen all weekend a group carrying tiki
torches in support of young can they say
right right they showed up in
charlottesville right i mean because
charlottesville we all know yeah yeah
yeah yeah right where donald trump and
the communication director jen goodman
tweeted even tweeted mcauliffe's
communication director yeah this is
disgusting and disqualifying but but
wait for it it turns out they were
actually sent by the pedo lincoln yeah
the lincoln project just you know the
lincoln project
yeah the lincoln project where it's uh
gosh nambla
[Music]
we changed the name i speak all the time
anna navarro used to be a republican it
is no longer the namla because today we
call it the lincoln project
we owe this to some internet just stop
what he said what he say say it again
say it again mr namla
i used to be a republican
i can't believe i'm so sober
an internet solution identified the tiki
torch carriers as democratic
operatives connect with the dots for us
here and and if we look at the picture
one more time we can actually even see
clayton
yeah right there making an appearance
wow and this got picked up by the media
everybody they were embarrassed and then
it did the correction
did not get picked up no the lincoln
project operatives you found that out by
twitter and other people saying hey wait
a minute hold on these guys aren't real
and then the media is like oh they say
it's just no way it's fake i mean come
on what is it what the leftist activists
consist look i i'm going to say
something here and people might get mad
at me saying this of course whether it's
deliberate no i i mean this weather
that's okay they're fine with everything
you've said right
yes
jul stop what'd he say
so i
uh that's like a technique she was like
no just stop i'm going to use my time
and i'm like got no time left
so um no i'm going to use my time you
got get get got no time hey just stop so
i'm going to say this whether deliberate
or not deliberate i'm not saying there's
some secret kabbalah people who are
planning this
the
hypersexualization of children and the
blurring of the lines between adulthood
and between children
we are entering remember people used to
say what's next pedophilia like don't
compare gay people to pedophile no one
was comparing it
people were saying
where is a line where we because
everyone has a line as far as what is
determined to be sexually moral and not
what you do in your own bedroom but what
is determined to be
acceptable in society at large
and when we are talking about right now
for example
this being given to your kids and let me
just this right here look this is
something that is available in fairfax
county okay
hardcore pornography and not even
softcore
that's a penis going into a child's
mouth to be clear they want to give this
to your kids and then you think about
the fact that the lincoln project was
found grooming children then you think
about the fact that one of our first
viral columns at least credit.com was
salon had an article i'm a pedophile but
i'm not a monster we did some background
work found that this person was actively
grooming a child and wrote no you're a
pedophile and you are a monster when you
then look at kyle rittenhouse
can't can't be chased by someone and
shoot them without hitting
serial pedophiles you do have to say
that the hypersexualization and
normalization of sexualization of
children
cuties i can go through the i can go on
forever baby i don't know that the i
don't know that anyone is doing it
deliberately
but it truly is sick it's twisted and we
are in the middle right now
of
pedophilic relations let's call it that
pedophilia being
normalized to a degree at least that it
never has
in our lifetime
or your parents lifetime or their
parents lifetime and we're not talking
about people getting married when they
were teenagers that's very different
right now this is the time where the
desensitizing you want to tell me you're
a 15 year old today you're a 12 year old
today
you follow lizzo
and uh and megan the stallion on
instagram
you go to school and this is what you
read
and your teachers that's what they tell
you and you tune into news on pride
month this is what you're saying you're
going to tell me that you this these
kids are not going to have
a fundamentally different world view
sexually
than you or your parents
and it's why parents you've got to get
to your kids young you've got to get to
your kids and have that talk with them
young so that they understand
at least whatever it is that that you
believe the confines should be sexually
with your kids because you know what i
remember i was taught and we have to
teach our son and you know twins if
someone shows you good pictures and bad
pictures right
because that's a common that's a common
theme with pedophiles who who groom kids
right they start start desensitizing
show them a little bit of porn that's
how it starts right so we have to have
that conversation
my dad i was talking with him about the
conversation that you know kind of he
had with me when i learned it as a kid
one second i'm going to tell my son tell
my daughter
when they grow up to know what are good
pictures and bad pictures of a stranger
gives them
what if they were handed this
okay i rest my case we are going to go
talk uh mike ward supreme court case big
win for free speech in canada this is a
huge deal uh and of course we could not
cover this at all because of the
offensive joke and its nature uh on
youtube so uh smash that like button one
more time right now before i leave
and if you miss us tomorrow we're still
here rumble 10 a.m eastern or mug club
youtube thank you
uh well how about you um oh page number
four
on the little girl's face off
you